a small village and a blast that sent
shock waves around the world initial
reports suggested Russia may have fired
it at Poland a NATO member killing two
peoples in Bali fresh from an emergency
meeting Rishi sunak and Joe Biden
discussed the attack but going into it
the American president sounded uncertain
now appears the missile that hit Poland
was fired by Ukrainian forces that's an
incoming Russian missile that has not
yet been confirmed
but this is what it looked like close up
farm machinery damaged the landscard
so of Russia firing weapons into a NATO
member put the world on high alert but
the Diplomatic show went on a mangrove
planting just as seeds of Doubt were
sown across the G20 about the
unpredictable absentee Vladimir Putin
Russia denied any involvement saying in
a statement it had launched no strikes
in the area and that the reports were a
deliberate propagation
what world leaders are now focusing on
are the missiles they say they know
Russia did fire 100 in Ukraine yesterday
alone
hitting missiles on NATO territory this
is a Russian missile attack on
collective security this is a very
significant escalation we must act
this was a moment of Jeopardy and things
are still unclear in a deeply Mercurial
era Clarity and calm heads will be
crucial